alright guys bangbang Spencer's back for
round two
thanks for doing this man I bet you
bought me absolutely to start this off
last time we did the rapid fire at the
end let's start off in the beginning
this time who's the best scorer in the
NBA
that's gonna be a Kevin Durant easy best
defender in the NBA best defender garter
or big cuz that takes both both I'm
gonna give BAM the best big defender
very versatile
Homer picks I also like him as a person
and then I say best guard defender drew
harden most underrated 3-point shooter
in NBA actually I'm gonna choose Kyrie
Irving ooh okay yeah he's actually a
really really really great three-point
shooter and I think you could all
necessarily lock in on how good of a
3-point shooter he is alright hardest
worker in the NBA
Oh Spence identity alright best [ __ ]
talker in the NBA that's tough I mean I
think I think Russ is always saying
funny stuff especially in the media okay
it's quote about Patrick Beverley was
actually hilarious all-time all-time
comedy
best business mind in the NBA best
business mind in terms of what they've
actually accomplished I go with LeBron
you know with the school and everything
he's done so for sure
alright best rapper of all time boy all
timer we taught my MBA rapper
let's go NBA rapper first and then
all-time om a rapper I'm going to move
it all time
I think body of work longevity you go
with jay-z alright that's all
take greatest biggie I like biggie
better though but I would say you have
to go with jay-z just all-time longevity
on that okay greatest basketball player
of all time Oh Kareem abdul-jabbar okay
why what's the logic so I the the go
debate it's always like I have to ask
like what do you define go s so for me I
say like the most dominant in terms of
like high school college pro like a
complete career of just excellence and
if you look at it like that Kareem is
not even close he like never lost in
high school I think it was 85 and two in
college he won the championship all
three years he played in college you
know then he goes to the NBA he's the
highest scorer of all time he's like
thinking the top 10 or so in rebounds
like you know he's got five rings like
yada yada yada the list goes on and on
um you know a lot of people measure
that's like who had the highest peak in
which case I would say Michael Jordan
for sure the six titles you know not
losing in the championship yeah yah -
all that stuff like I agree but just
spanning a complete career like to go
from you know high school to college
like eight years and you only lose two
games and then you know you got five
tiles in the league and a bit uh
high-scoring mark of all time like it's
kind of unfathomable yeah so good body
of work there what's the greatest what's
the greatest prank that's happened in an
NBA locker room that fans don't know
about
I'm not divulging locker room pranks I'm
not I'm not gonna be that guy the look
on your face told us everything we need
to know all right so let's get into some
of the stuff you've been doing you I
feel like you have seized the moment
with quarantine
it started with proposing the playoff
system mm-hmm so maybe just give kind of
quick two seconds like where did that
come from and then what was the reaction
from the league or the team or anything
like that when when you threw that out
there so really it it all stemmed from
obvious
according to number one and the number
two the conversation you have with your
boys you know just like texting and
stuff like that and you start
spitballing ideas you know you get stuff
from like John Geiger and then you
notice other people that I talked to
Jeremy is one of my best friends and so
when you formulate and put it all
together I decided to tweet it see what
the fans thought about it you know my
model in terms of social media or motto
in terms of social media it's just you
know I want to feel like you're having a
conversation with me so a lot of that
stuff that I put on Twitter especially
um is really just like my actual
thoughts I'm just kind of talking you
know the league actually called me about
it and asked me to explain it because
they want to incorporate some of the
ideas you know people thought they might
be mad at me but they actually really
enjoyed that part yeah I gotta assume
that there's some people at the league
who they enjoy the the banter of the fan
engagement and kind of forward thinking
and there's some people who probably
more old-school just like hey we got it
you know everyone else stay out of our
job 1,000% what option I mean you
anytime you did them with a legacy
system there's always gonna be people
that are like look if we just do it our
way it'll always work you know and then
there's obviously some upstarts that are
gonna be within the ranks they're like
hey you know maybe maybe that guy's on
to something so I know there's a some
controversy within that and some going
back and forth within that for me I mean
nothing that I do is designed to harm
the league in any way like obviously why
would I you know start playing
basketball three four years old wanted
to do nothing else for playing the NBA
why would I try to then like take down
the NBA while I'm only six years in and
potentially have like another what seven
eight years to play or something like
that you know this there's always been
about enhancing any any additional
structure it's been about like engaging
the fans because in the end of the day
like the fans as we see are the most
important piece of the ecosystem if you
guys watch you know we still have a job
we still have a you know a league a a
system of being an ecosystem but if you
guys don't watch then we might as well
be playing in the park I mean it'd be a
lot of fun but we'd also have to get a
day job yeah what do you think
kind of the fan relationship looks like
coming out of quarantine right do you
think that games end up getting played
with no fans in the stadium or do we
kind of wait told they can come back
like what does that look like from where
we're sitting today and kind of end of
May of 2020 I mean with the immediate
proposal really on there there's no
there's no way that's gonna be fans you
know with finishing this season and
potentially playing obviously these
playoffs and and trying to get a true
into the 2020 season there's no way they
could do that with fans such a condensed
time I think 2021 we'll see what that
brings if there's a lot of headway on a
vaccine or we just have a lot more
knowledge based on you know what this
virus kind of means and its implications
then I think we will see fans return I
mean I know that's what the owners are
pushing for and what the league
collectively is pushing for yeah whoever
ends up winning whatever that ends up
meaning for the 2020 final season here
is there an asterisk next to that win
like because it wasn't a regular season
do people kind of look at it differently
1,000% and you gotta remember like an
ash tree doesn't necessarily mean good
nor bad you know it just means different
I know and we could take like let's say
the front worker for example we'll take
the Lakers right LeBron will have won
another championship he's on a quest to
you know try to usurp Jordan is you know
the the goal or the most Dominator
whatever I call it
Jordan fans will say there are no that
championship shouldn't count it was a
weird season you know the quarantine
stuff and they play at a neutral site
and so it wasn't near as tough is Jordan
going on the road and beating the Jazz
and the shot and all that stuff but then
LeBron fans will say well because he had
to deal with all this stuff and because
he had to go through all these things it
makes him it makes that champ [ __ ]
better you know he had to deal with you
know Kobe's passing and the turmoil of
the league and the quarantine and being
offered so much time and he came back
and he was or wasn't rusty and all other
stuff so when I when I put out that
comment about the Astros I was merely
just saying it causes more controversy
than debate I wasn't saying it was
either good nor bad yeah and it almost
makes those two
like more lively right having all of
this it's not so much just hey how many
championships now you get into all the
nuances and me and everyone else knows
that's really what what people love the
debate is all the the kind of nuance
1,000 percent well that's what really
structures a debate because if you
really were only basing it upon like one
hard fact and there would be no debate
because the one hard fact would tell you
you know I'm saying the answer yeah give
us an update on the tokenization so your
original proposal came out obviously the
NBA wasn't so hot on it you kind of
reworked a little bit where are you with
that right now and kind of what updates
do you have for people yeah so I mean
obviously I always have to preface these
things by saying you gotta contact the
broker-dealer on file which Oregon
capital you know we're doing everything
obviously on the up-and-up it was for
red creditor accredited investors only
but pretty much you know we started the
process back well sure when we start the
process and went through all the
legalese and everything it was shoot 18
maybe 20 months ago now but when we kind
of started talking to the NBA was in
September of last year obviously like
you said they were too hot on it we
continue to go forward talk to them kind
of settled on a structure that was more
like a pilot it's it's a bond obviously
and then you know attaching a safe to it
for the larger business investment as
well but you know that like I said
multiple times I view this as the start
of an asset class it's about unlocking
liquidity and and creating fan
engagement so my bond is not necessarily
the most interesting thing in the world
but as this continues to scale there's
going to be a host of different things
you know any business can offer any
product they want and you know we all
individually are our own businesses yeah
and I think what's really interesting
about this right if you came out with
some that was really really innovative
and then you kind of get walked back a
little bit to something that you know
your words is more boring but it still
gets it done right and it's almost like
it's more important to get it done than
it is to have the most innovative
sexiest structure right out of the gate
is that fair
oh that's when thoughts were sent
Pharisee and that's why I try to you
know communicate to people a lot when
you know they they see things like to go
farming they show you things like the
initial kind of spitballing of the
offering and what was reported or miss
reported in some places you know they
think if you don't do the absolute
sexiest thing that you somehow fail but
in a lot of ways you don't necessarily
think that you're going to get all that
accomplished when you're doing dealing
with legacy systems you understand
they're gonna draw their hard line
somewhere but what you're saying is this
is all of what I want to do now tell me
what you're going to allow me to do and
where we can work together and so
there's typically a midline that you
know you get to because you were bold
enough to say what it is that you want
it to do but if you come out and you and
you tiptoe they typically would just try
to hush you and move you over to the
side and say you're not gonna do it and
then you know those people pack their
bags and go home you have to have enough
gumption to you know really kind of try
it yeah do you think that there would
have been a different approach from the
league's perspective if it wasn't so
much drawn to the the player contract
and had been more like sponsorships or
something like that or is it just
generally the idea of tokenizing a
revenue stream from a player and having
fans potentially invest in it that's
really what was kind of they were trying
to wrap their head around quite honestly
I think it's uh both you know I think
they don't necessarily want the the
athlete taking control of the revenue
streams or their fan engagement or
really blurring that line between
themselves and the fans and really
making it a cohesive unit in a sense I
think because their jurisdiction does
deal with player contracts that's why
they were allowed to say something if I
was doing that with you know Nike money
for example they could hate it all they
want to but if they came out against it
I could very easily just say hey like
this has absolutely nothing to do with
you you know so but that's where they
had some jurisdiction but at the same
time I don't think they would have liked
it regardless yeah and then you came out
with this go fund me which when I saw it
I literally said this dudes either the
biggest genius in the world or this is
going nowhere
it's kind of what was the the impetus
for even starting it and then kind how
did you structure it yeah no so sort of
go for anything it's another kind of
tool of family engagement right like
there's all these factors that play into
a person making a free agency decision
and simply we can they try to keep it
you know off to the side right we talk
about market size fanbase we talk about
state taxes if a shoe company is going
to push you to a team that has a lot of
history or a team that you know has a
big media following or whatever it is or
your hometown etc you know there's all
these different factors your family your
friends all that right well what if you
involve the fans in some of those
decision-making processes right like the
CBA pretty much states that you can't
like take a discount or anything like
that so you know when I tweeted and went
back in read the CBA I was like okay I
have to take out the minimum portion of
it but there's nothing in there that
says they can't be factors in your
decisions quite frankly if I'm choosing
a team based upon you know their their
fan base and you know how big of a
global presence they are then I'm
choosing it because of those fans you
know I just didn't tell the fans that
they're why I'm choosing them you know
and so kind of reimagining that know
when I set the actual price once again I
said it sky high because there was no
way that it was gonna get there and the
way I chose that I actually just take my
three favorite numbers put them together
multiplied it by the price of Bitcoin
and got it people people thought I was
choosing like market value or something
else I literally took and I wrote it I
took twenty six twenty five point eight
and then multiply that by the price of
Bitcoin which is probably I think like
ninety two hundred at the time or
something in that range
and that's how we got the sky-high
number and the reason why I said you
know if even if we're a dime short it
all goes to charity because it about it
was about the idea in the concept how
can we enhance training gauge and how
can we bring more people in how can this
ecosystem thrive in the middle of Kovach
if there are no fans in the in the
stands next year but guys want to do
some things that kind of keep people in
trenched in the game well what
if they literally chose a player's
destination you know or of a player had
you know a set of three destinations he
said you know what I'm torn between you
know Brooklyn and two other teams you
guys pick you know and and and obviously
they wouldn't be able to talk about
money and things like that cuz that's
between the player and the team
negotiating but if that if that was
right for him and he could do that
and if we go fund me campaign or another
blockchain based you know system allowed
them to have that kind of voting power
in there then I mean there's nothing
saying that they couldn't do that so you
know like I said it's picked sky high
number under I wouldn't reach it it
would end up in a charity donation which
you know I wanted to do good during
Cobra as well but it was all about the
concept and the idea yeah my brother
texted me I didn't see it at first when
you posted it and he texted me he goes
what's he doing and I as soon as I read
it I said he might be a billionaire by
the end of this if people give him
twenty five twenty five million dollars
a Bitcoin whoa like what did happen I
would have definitely been a shock to
say the least but yeah I mean the plan
was definitely always to give the money
charity that's why you know I wrote in
there like that yeah it's like as part
of this is Lisa this question of the
GoFundMe is a hard one to do it's had a
sky-high price but but this concept of
like the fans having a say you could
imagine somebody building some you know
kind of auto magic governance system
let's say and now fans can actually act
almost as like mini GM's right yeah do
you feel like that's closer to a world
that will move towards an all sports not
just the NBA or do you feel like it's
just such a big leap from where we are
and owners and teams across the major
sports they just don't want to even get
into that game where fans have that much
type of control of players and how
things are put together I don't think
they necessarily want to get into that
and maybe I'm 20 years off here but
you're gonna have to get there
eventually you know with the more we
kind of move into you know a gaming
cypher all that stuff part of the
attraction of that is the
trol you know I mean like that's just
kind of like psychologically speaking
part of the attraction so you know when
when you want to continue to compete
especially with live sports you're going
to want to involve these people you know
as much you possibly can you look at the
Green Bay Packers for example they have
one of the most rabid fan bases and
that's because you know a lot of those
people own shares and feel like they are
really entrenched in on the field with
the Packers that's what you want to
create you know and like I said it
doesn't necessarily mean that you know a
fan says alright Spencer we're trading
you tomorrow but it maybe it does mean
that if I come to a four agency decision
and I am choosing between Brooklyn and
one other team that I say hey you know
what normally I may flip a coin or I may
ask my mom or I may ask this or I'm
asked that well you know what I'm gonna
let you guys decide you know and and if
that's right for that player and that
specific business then that is you know
I'm saying something that that that can
happen and I think it wouldn't the NBA
will see that that will enhance the
ecosystem because they will feel
personally responsible now for their
team's success or failure if you tell me
to stay on the Nets right and then we
don't win a championship and you feel
like I'm the reason we don't win then
you're gonna feel also personally liable
for the loss but if you do win and
you're gonna feel like you personally
had something to do with the win and at
the end of the day fan is short for
fanatic you want them to feel entrenched
in that environment in that ecosystem
and so the closer you can bring them
into you know the bubble the better yeah
and it feels like there's other aspects
of sports or I mean literally just if
you own a seat licensed at let's say the
New York Giants Stadium right obviously
the value of the seat license goes up if
they're better it goes down if they suck
right and so there's there's elements of
this it's just not as direct of like hey
here's my vote for where you should go
right now it sounds like that that's the
big leap forward next yep I think you're
right on that yeah it talked to us a
little bit about during quarantine like
what are players doing right now I've
seen you post on Instagram a couple
times like you're still trying to work
out and all that but like how hard is
that given that you're still somewhat
expected to be ready to go at a moment's
notice really as a professional athlete
but then you've got kind
whole healthcare crisis and lockdown
going on yeah that's definite probably
the hardest part to a restart I think I
think it's the part that people aren't
necessarily talking about enough I know
we have concerns about coal but
obviously we have families and and and
people that we take care of that you
know we were worried about but there's
also an injury risk you know coming back
too quickly if they do decide to do that
I know guys are trying to work out to
the best of their ability you know some
have access to more things and other
depend upon you know their environment
right now with which city they're in but
yeah I mean it's tough you know most
gyms are locked down obviously so
getting basketball working right now
unless you're a max player and have you
know a gym in your house and all that
stuff is not the easiest thing to do
yeah and is there concern about like
coronavirus itself obviously hey I don't
pull hamstring twist an ankle that type
of stuff is just what we'll call it rust
right from not played for a couple of
weeks but is there actual like CO vid
stuff especially since a couple of
players tested positive earlier in the
year yeah I mean I think there is you
know if you talk around the NBA
everybody is cautious I won't say scared
because we understand the demographic
that we're in you know being between 20
and 35 and obviously in pretty good
shape that we're probably not you know
like death risk and we're not in that
demographic but there there's so little
information on it right now the you know
people are cautious you know and and and
rightfully so yeah you want to pick one
of your teammates who you think will
come back least in shape at all this
who's at home eating all the snacks
who's at home eating all the snacks do
Pinson I love it I love it
last dance has gotten a ton of attention
the documentary on Michael Jordan what
was your general takeaways from from
watching it um you really get a glimpse
into the mind of you know who Michael
Jordan was and what may I'm so great you
get to see kind of
how the bulgur almonds kind of like the
Beatles in a sense because of the league
that that's something that obviously I
never really got to experience because I
was too young you know when they're
really on their run I was four or five
years old so you understand who Michael
Jordan is how great he was as a player
and all that stuff but y'all remember
all the fanfare necessarily surrounding
it Dennis Rodman might be my favorite
player of all time now but yeah just
overall it was it was it was interesting
to see I mean really I wish they could
have dived or doe even deeper into
everything that went on cuz obviously
you know you only have so much time and
in a ten-part doc yeah I saw a tweet
about Rodman somebody said like the
first week was if you want to know how
good Dennis Rodman was he had Michael
Jordan chasing around Vegas to get him
to come to practice was you telling me
this man was you know a multi time NBA
champion he basically was doing drugs
drinking going to WWE matches like they
laid out everything in the documentary
and he still was you know not even the
best guy on his team right and by the
way like all that happens because
there's no social media imagine some guy
there's no way there's no way you would
get Eve iterated by you know coaching
stuff fans media all that like there'd
be no way because somebody pull out the
camera phone and you know video evidence
is a lot different than hearsay yeah
that's not even possible no I'm just a
match like I was watching it and when
the when he disappears after one of the
games right and they find out he well I
was sitting there saying like imagine
today of a player just disappeared right
everyone's like where is he you would
have fans going nuts all over social
media gonna be an old global manhunt to
find the player oh yeah well I mean he'd
be found because he'd be walking through
an airport whether it was private or not
it somebody was to have a picture and be
like hey I'm in you know Cleveland Ohio
and I just saw Dennis Rodman and
everybody be like what the heck is he
doing it Cleveland Ohio so yeah it would
it would be over quick yeah and then
what's your take on a I saw like horse
grant
I think Scottie Pippen a couple of guys
were unhappy with how the way
the documentary was put together like
what's kind of your takeaway from that I
mean I think the scottie pippen one
actually kind of caught me off guard
because if you look at it the way
Michael Jordan talked about him he
basically said like I don't win without
you you know and for somebody that is
notorious for being extremely hard and
unforgiving and holding grudges and
racially competitive for him to
basically say like hey I needed Scottie
you're upset I didn't want him on to I
needed him on the team that's a huge
compliment and then you know the other
stuff that went down I mean a lot I was
Scotty's decision so you know I I don't
really have too much to say on the
Scottie front on the Horace Grant front
I could see how that was tough you know
they they blamed him for snitching
effectively but you know one of the
things he said was that for the guy to
publish the story he needed to people at
minimum to corroborate the story so he
said you know forget the fact that one
I'm denying that I ever said anything
but two if he needed to people it
couldn't have only been matt says that
like it couldn't have only been me so
like how are you guys solely pinning
this on me there's got to be somebody
else so I could definitely see what
Horrocks grant you know felt a certain
way to Scott the Scottie thing is you
know maybe it's personal or something I
don't know like I'm not I don't know
those guys but I can't really I can't
begin to comment on that yeah my two
favorite parts of the entire thing is
one the Steve Kerr story where they get
into like the fist fight and it just
showed like one I think Kerr
understanding like hey if you stand up
and basically back it up Jordan will
respect you and I think that's kind of
like he just saw him over and over and
then to is the security guard with the
jheri-curl man and like I guess part of
as you're watching like how much of the
behind-the-scenes stuff right so
literally we see Jordan like throwing
quarters with security guards before the
game I'm assuming that a lot of that is
they pull the best parts right you know
and put it into a documentary but like
is that the general atmosphere before
the games for players in the locker room
or did you feel like that was like oh
that must have been fun in the 90s
because we're not doing any of that type
of stuff now
well not necessary for ters and as of
now people don't really have their own
personal locker rooms away from the
locker room but in terms of the banter
and the joking and you know that type of
stuff yeah that's that's that's
definitely consistent in my locker you
got to remember like these are 15 highly
competitive guys who are about to you
know kind of go to war in a sense you
know you don't want to be on all the
time you want to be on you know an hour
two hours before the game up until the
game ends but when the game does in
especially after wins you want to kind
of be able to turn off and you know so
in those moments you're definitely going
to see more quarter type of atmosphere
and guys laughing joking with each other
yeah makes sense this is last time we
talked there's been a bunch of chaos in
the financial markets look we won't even
pretend that we know what's going on but
just a lot of chaos how have you thought
about kind of your investment portfolio
and things that you've looked at from
investment opportunities like how has
that evolved over the last eight to ten
weeks is all this has been going on well
I know a lot of things begin hammered
you know obviously the crypto market as
well I mean if you trade it you've been
able to kind of capture some of the
fluctuations both ways but I don't think
anybody could have predicted obviously
COBIT as a whole I think the the
scariest part even though you know it is
seemingly necessary at the moment in
terms of like you know the SBA or you
know the the weather where they call it
there are twelve hundred dollars a month
or stimulus there we go it's is turning
the helicopter money man like it's it's
crazy because you know they just printed
six trillion dollars over last what is
it like several months how how we
recover from this I have I have no idea
you know I mean we all obviously have
our theories and hope it goes one
direction in part because obviously it
benefits us as well because we're kind
of part of that Vanguard
you know solution but it's it's tough I
don't I don't think this gets better
quickly because I don't think people
necessarily understand the ramifications
like if the market goes through a normal
cycle I would I would assume in the u.s.
at some point time has to experience
hyperinflation I mean it's it's a little
it's a lot of money it's a lot of money
with their printing and they're not
showing signs of slowing down either
yeah and I guess like NBA players or
other athletes are in a very unique
position right because most people who
would have the type of income that an
NBA player has they're either very very
deep on finance like literally an expert
you know whether trader investor or
whatever they built big businesses etc
one of the trends over the last couple
of years in the league has been people
getting very sophisticated about
business about investing and and all
that so do you hear teammates or other
players in the league talking about this
stuff right now in terms of maybe not
like hey the stock market's down but the
the more like structural issues or the
longer-term impact of this type of stuff
or they just focus on playing basketball
right now and not talk about as much you
know you actually hear more
conversations about like the stock
market being down or people getting into
VC and things like that I don't think
people really kind of gone deep enough
to really talk about like the actual
structural issues of the economy you
know or the way we stop the Oh a kind of
artificially stop the OE recession with
the bells etc etc those are things that
aren't really talked about in VA locker
room yeah I mean it's it's tough man I
mean to be able to have disposable
income and during this time period is
definitely a blessing obviously if you
invest into the storm and you are able
to kind of strike right you know you
have good people around you that are
able to kind of stay in the right
direction
you have the capability to really come
out you know more than on top on the
back end but but it's gonna get tough
for everybody you know if the league
wasn't coming back I mean you know
talking about cutting salaries for you
know as a period of time and there's
already
crow system so it already holds a
portion of the salaries and all your
other stuff so you know it's it's not as
easy on us as some may seem and it's
just it's a tough it's a tough time for
everybody you know it just really is
yeah and I guess the last thing I want
to finish up on is the smartest players
obviously are surrounded by a lot of
smart people and these people have been
investing capital for athletes and
others for a long period of time how
much has Bitcoin and crypto kind of
infiltrated those portfolios or those
conversations with what I'll call kind
of that the financial advisors to
players right so players obviously my
expectation would be some of them care
some of them don't and it's all personal
preference but the financial advisors
are supposed to understand all the
different asset classes and give
recommendations what's going on there
with Bitcoin in those financial advisors
I don't talk to financial advisors that
frequently in terms of like others but I
mean I definitely have heard a rise in
you know the frequency of blockchain
being brought up amongst those
conversations you know obviously
everybody knows about 2017 boom
everybody else about the crash and kind
of its fluctuations now in between but I
think people are really starting to kind
of expand their horizons because they're
not understanding what's going to you
know come next I don't think anybody
really does you know we all have our
guesses but I think as they're starting
to say hold up this doesn't really make
too much sense and it's not just our
economy it's going through it there's a
lot of economies most of them really
around the world that are going through
something like how can we start to
protect our clients and obviously make
their money because you know they get
paid by asset under management so the
better they do you know the sorry the
better the the client does the more
money they make as well and I mean we
just we just had a you know Tudor Jones
not too long ago say you know he's now
in Bitcoin so you know it's it's
definitely gonna continue the bug is
gonna continue to spray it so I'm
excited about that for sure to end I
usually ask questions to questions but
I've already asked them to you so I got
two new ones for you if you if you're
the NBA commissioner for a day what's
the
one rule that you would change in the
league oh I would allow player contracts
and ownership of teams to be
democratized if they so chose bring them
all in I love it I love it
last question is if you were President
of the United States for a day what's
the one thing you would do what did you
just think of that's a lot I know how is
there a drone nah man that's that's
tough that's tough because obviously we
talk about finance and it's a you know
predominantly financial platform I mean
you got prison reform you got all types
of things the president thing is it's
hard yeah I mean but one of the things
that definitely six out of my mind has
to be has to be prison reform we look at
everybody making money off legal
marijuana right now and how many people
have life senses and 20 and 25 years
sensors on marijuana like I you you got
to change that you have to you know and
then the prison system being privatized
and all that stuff you know people are
making money you know they're making
money off of the wrongdoings of other
people which to me is a wrongdoing
because if you're if you can incentivize
somebody to do something wrong because
you have financial gain then you're part
of the problem you're pushing them
towards that you know end goal so you
can profit right so I would say from a
personal standpoint that would be one
thing for a personal gain perspective I
mean we get started doing something
about printing this money and I switch
it over you know what which currencies
we're gonna use and how are we going to
use them so that's that's where I would
go but yeah
that's where I'm at I love it man listen
it's always a pleasure to do this with
you you you got a lot of ideas and the
part that I like about it is most people
who have ideas they're unwilling to kind
of share them with the world because
they're scared that the backlash right
but III tell you all times look now I
need cherem you get in the comments
right you're there you're there and
you're explaining you're defending right
you're doing all this kind of stuff
which I think it's important right
because we live in a society where as
more and more people become afraid to do
that less innovation happens right you
need explore those ideas in order to
kind of come up with where we're going
next and you gotta you gotta understand
the value of different opinions you know
some people obviously go crazy in the
comments and just want to be rude that's
one thing but you know there are people
that asked really thought-provoking
questions and they make me expand you
know they and they made me explain why
it's nuanced this way or nuanced that
way or maybe their little nugget
actually propels the idea forward so you
know I welcome in like I said I hope
Twitter continues to be a conversation
platform for me
absolutely man where where can people go
to find out more if they want to learn
about the organization dream fan shares
dot-com and other than that just contact
right Orianna capital broker deal on
record like I said try to not speak
about this in detail too much it's
because you know FCC FINRA I love you
guys my dog I specialist guy appreciate
you doing this we'll do it again soon
appreciate you